do you truly think that we're gonna get
onto a bitcoin standard i don't know how
you stop it bitcoin is like this vortex
of positive incentives everyone's
cooperating competing in the marketplace
to try and secure economic value for
themselves we all have an incentive to
hold that in a medium that is most
resistant to the opinions of others i
want to hold my money my economic life
force or monetary energy a sailor might
say i want to hold that in something
that no one else's opinions or behaviors
or actions can affect right the most
untouchable asset is the most desirous
asset and that's what bitcoin is can't
inflate it can't confiscate it can't
interrupt the network can't turn it off
can't reverse it can't stop it i can't
imagine bitcoin not having an incredible
amount of demand in a world where we're
freezing the bank accounts of peaceful
protesters where we're freezing the
foreign reserves of russia when they go
to war this pain that people and
institutions are going to feel that's
going to push them into and towards this
untouchable asset the layer puncher